Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 25th,
2019 what's going on?
How,
why?
Yeah,
I'm recording this in New York City right before I get on a plane,
they go fly to London.
Um,
do my little run through a the U K tape my special and then come home and I
ain't doin shit.
[inaudible] Shit,
I'm taping this Sunday,
the 24th.
I'm tough day.
Definitely a tough day.
They have in this memorial for a Steven Brody Stevens,
um,
tonight at the comedy store.
And unfortunately I'm in New York and I can't be there and I'm crushed that I
can't be there and say all the things I would have liked to have said,
which really is the strange thing about when somebody dies.
Do you ever notice when somebody dies then you somehow,
immediately,
no emotionally exactly what you wished you have,
you would have said to the person,
it's really weird,
but I kind of get it because that's a heavy thing to do to somebody.
Like,
what would I say to this person if I knew they were going to die tomorrow?
If you just fucking hit them with that,
whether it's sitting there eating a fucking Cobb salad,
they're going to be looking at you like,
whoa dude.
Hey,
let's try to keep it light here.
Okay.
Um,
but yeah,
I just,
that fucking guy,
my God,
that guy made me laugh.
Like I don't even know how to describe it.
TheW and,
and it was the way,
like nobody ever made me laugh that hard.
The way he made me laugh,
it was completely 100%.
Just a unique,
unique,
unique sense of humor.
Um,
just really,
you know what's funny is I've been,
I've been talking to all of these comics of bottom over the last couple of days
here and we're all like quoting his jokes and it's like,
if you don't know Brody,
it's,
it's kind of like he kind of have to know him and he kinda had to be familiar
with this act to underst cause it was his fucking cadence half the time.
Like,
um,
it's a good example.
I remember one time I was down at the comedy store,
we were in the main room and I was with my wife,
Nia and Brody went on stage and I swear to God that fucking genius went on stage
and for 10 minutes described his dream apartment and there was no set ups,
no punchlines.
He was just describing and in like this sort of,
I can't even,
it was like Zillow speak meets like this amazing comedic cadence.
I,
I don't even,
I can't even remember what he said.
Me and Nia,
we're just looking at each other and were just dying laughing and I just,
it was like,
you know,
ceiling to floor windows,
stepping down into the living room.
And when he said that wife literally almost fell out of her chair.
I know this won't seem funny to a lot of you because you didn't know him and
nobody can recreate what that the way that that guy did what he did.
But when he said stepping down into the living room,
like I just put my head down on the table and was crying,
laughing at the same time.
Also for the first time ever in my life noticing,
um,
how much reverence,
if that's the right word,
that I held anybody,
Eh,
like any room that you stepped down in,
into,
in an apartment is unbelievably classy.
And I had no idea that I thought that.
And I think the whole crowd along with me suddenly realized in that moment that
like we all felt that and had never expressed it and Brody had just expressed it
and,
and he acted out stepping down and he sort of crouched into the living room and,
uh,
it was just amazing,
you know?
And it wasn't,
and also to like,
probably behind all of that on the underneath was the sadness of,
of,
you know,
like what he wanted and was he going to get it and all of that type of stuff
that was just very relatable.
And um,
I don't know,
man.
It's like,
I have this weird,
this is a weird one where I'm really sad selfishly from myself,
but I'm not like,
I don't know,
I'm not the most spiritual guy,
but I just,
I feel like,
you know,
his,
his journey was like complete,
I guess,
you know,
that's how I have to look at it or else it becomes too sad.
And when I really look at how we affected everybody and just the fucking
outpouring that was on,
um,
Twitter and I'll cite t would have been that,
you know,
that he,
that he was trending on Twitter for two days now.
Um,
I dunno,
it was just,
it was really that,
that part of it was like a cool thing to see.
And I,
I used to,
I tried to sit down and watch that show that he did with,
uh,
Zach Galifianakis,
by the way,
shout out to Zach for loaning his name,
but that,
so Brody could do that show.
And um,
it was just too soon to sit there and watch it and watch them struggle.
I just can't imagine having them,
um,
a mental illness
where you just literally just walking around fighting your own brain and the way
that he was able to do that and not lash out at other people and just be so kind
and so sweet to everybody and it just so fucking funny,
man.
It's like,
it's really,
it's,
it's an end of an era in,
um,
at the comedy store like this and there's really not going to be,
there's not idea.
There's no,
there was nobody before after him that that was,
that was like that guy.
And furthermore,
he truly,
in the purest sense was a,
um,
was it comic's comic where a lot of times that gets thrown around,
Oh,
this guy's a comic comic or she's comic's comic and it's somebody that's also
selling a lot of tickets.
It's almost like,
it means it's a comedian that made it,
but other comedians still like that person and don't resent their success is
sort of the way a comic's comic is sort of the,
I guess definition of it,
if the way I kind of see it.
But Brody was he,
he was,
he was a comic's comic in that he was really for us,
like the wait staff and people that manage comics and people who had watched
that amount of comedy to understand how unique he was and how different it was.
And I love going on the Internet now and all these people were just discovering
them and some people get numb,
but there's a lot of people being like,
this guy is funny,
this guy sucks.
Um,
I'm sure you guys are sad but this guy,
so that makes me feel even better.
It's like,
yeah,
you don't get it.
You don't get it.
Cause you're not a fucking comedian and you just have like,
you know where your comedic air is.
Tay.
Two guys walk into a bar and the rabbi says like,
you're not going to get this fucking guy.
Like you have to watch a lot of comedy to see,
um,
how funny this guy was.
And uh,
um,
I'm really gonna miss him in,
Oh man.
I remember when I was doing a,
I was,
what was it,
the odd ball,
the odd ball tour.
And,
uh,
I had gone on,
the crowd was fucking,
you know,
it was like,
I don't know,
fucking eight,
9,000 people and it was shit and it's just a such a rush to be on in front of.
And Brody was hosting and Chris Delea was going on next.
And uh,
I've always loved Chris.
Like he just was like,
you know,
he reminded me of like a Boston comic word as far as like he could get up in
front of from early on,
get up in front of a big crowd and kill it.
A level that was considering headlining the way I learned what it sounds like,
what killing sounded like he was doing.
So,
um,
you know,
he was on his way out and I was saying,
Oh,
do you wait to go out there?
It's going to be fucking amazing.
I sit and I asked him,
I was like,
you want me to take a picture?
Uh,
or I didn't know if I asked him,
whatever.
So he was walking out and I wanted to take a picture of Chris right when he got
to the microphone because the lights were up and you could see how big the crowd
was and I thought it'd be a cool thing for him to have and retweet or whatever.
And I was just focused on Chris.
Right.
And Brody it done the fucking intro and I didn't realize he was in frame when it
,
cause I was just looking at Chris to try and frame it and I like the picture and
I was unaware that Steven did this,
you know with his baseball background,
he has a pitcher and I forget what he,
Arizona,
Arizona State,
I think it was Arizona State,
I'm not sure.
And He,
you don't,
you know that warm up that pitchers do.
Like when we see like spring training before the game where they're walking and
they put their hand out like straight out in front of them and like above their
head and then they just kick their leg up with their toe,
their Clita,
their toe touches their hand.
I guess he used to do that.
I,
that was the first time I ever saw him do it and when I click the photo,
he was walking off stage doing that and he had literally kicked his foot.
Was that the apex almost touching his hand with his,
his head tucked down a little bit and I,
it just,
I saw that and I just thought it just,
it was just so him,
I just started fucking laughing and I was just as a comedian,
like why did he do that?
Was was that for the crowd?
Was that for him?
What was the person in the crowd as they're watching Krista Leah walking on
stage and then in the peripheral they just see this guy walking off kicking his
head is fucking phone up to his head,
like a spring training fucking picture and the,
and the grapefruit league and for the rest of that fucking Tor,
you know,
when you know,
you get lonely on the road,
I would just look at that picture and I would just die laughing.
And so many people that I showed who weren't in standup didn't understand why
they would just sort of like,
wow,
that guy can kick his foot up high or whatever.
They didn't get it or it wasn't hitting them the way it was hitting me,
but I just,
um,
I don't know,
man.
Uh,
I don't know what else to say.
I just,
uh,
it's just,
it's really obviously really sad,
but he just was,
I don't know,
the way that guy touched me by what he did.
I have this weird sort of,
mmm.
I Dunno.
I can't yet,
definitely am really,
really sad,
but it's not that same kind of sadness.
I,
and I'm not the most spiritual guy,
but if there's,
if there's anything,
he's there,
you know,
after this.
Cause,
uh,
I dunno,
I,
I never heard anybody say one bad fucking word about that guy who's always such
a night and he's fucking hilarious and all that.
So anyways,
there goes another one,
so.
MMM.
I Dunno,
I guess,
I don't know.
He would get frustrated.
I mean the whole fucking,
his whole thing is just like his whole life was like an Oscar winning movie as
far as the way he battled,
like what he battled and our positive.
He stayed
and like I always wondered like what that what it was like for him to have all
like the best comics being like,
dude,
you're like one of the funniest guys ever.
And then not getting that from the mainstream in a while,
you know,
battling all that other shit.
I mean,
and then to not turn bitter and not be a fucking asshole.
It's unbelievable.
It really is.
So
I now that like his life is complete,
like kind of looking back on it,
it was like,
it was weird.
Like,
yeah,
he was on his,
what's that grateful dead song?
It reminded me of that,
you know,
that that song ripple the way they say,
uh,
what the fuck,
how does that lyric go?
Let me look this up here.
It says there,
there's a road,
no simple highway between the dawn and the dark at night.
And if you go,
no one may follow.
That path is meant for your steps alone.
Yeah.
I feel like if they ever do like a documentary,
which I'm sure they're going to like,
that should be,
that should be the tone because I don't know,
I don't know if I'm saying this right,
but like,
I dunno what that guy did was just so fucking unique in this.
There's a loneliness to be in that fucking unique.
And the fact,
like I said,
that he didn't turn into a fucking asshole about it and was just so nice and
supportive to everybody.
You know?
I don't know.
I don't measure up to that,
put it that way.
So
thank you to Brody Stevens and all of that.
Steven Brody,
Stevens,
all those fucking times you made me laugh and everybody else.
And,
uh,
I dunno.
I think for the rest of my life,
I'm going to be going to,
yes,
you got it.
It just feels good to say it.
I,
I mean,
half of my conversations I think I had with him,
sadly enough was just me imitating him.
It was,
he was so fun.
I would just start talking,
talking like him.
So anyways,
uh,
that's my 2 cents.
And,
um,
there's a bunch of clips of them.
If this made you interested,
uh,
definitely look them up.
And,
uh,
all right.
I guess I don't know where the fuck do you go from there?
Jesus Christ,
Dude.
Like,
okay.
Oh,
is this what being old is now?
I mean it's just fucking every bike
to comics die more than other people because I,
I,
you know,
I have a whole list of everybody that died cause I don't want to forget them and
I'm up to like fucking 32 comedians.
Yeah.
All guys to every single one of them.
I'll tell you for all the bitch in the women are doing and stand up,
at least you're still alive.
You can still do sets.
Um,
I was actually talking to de Rosa and we would just,
we would tell him Steven Brody Stevens fucking stories.
Um,
it's the weirdest thing like on this,
cause all these people that have died,
there's always been like a sadness of blah,
blah,
blah.
And with everybody I've talked to about,
it's like you end up crying,
laughing,
telling stories rather than crying,
crying,
you know,
and we were trying to remember his,
another guy,
you should look up as far as like,
just fucking hilarious.
Who Died?
MMM.
Is it a comic?
Rasheed Thurmond,
t H.
U.
R m.
O.
N.
D.
And he died right when I went to La and I remember a young guy to like 36 37
years old.
It was another,
another great one.
So anyways,
where the fuck did you go from there?
Um,
I've been running my set here in New York City,
New York City,
one of the most caring comedy crowds.
You're going to be in front of Jesus Christ.
I swear.
I feel like a three year comic when I perform in New York City.
Now I don't know what the fuck is going on.
Um,
part of it's me because of this,
the overly sensitive fucking horse shit that's going on.
It's forcing me to go in the other direction.
Yeah.
You know,
to just,
it's just,
it's still,
you know,
it's the balance of the universe.
It's like if,
if you're going to fucking
try to push me in this,
this direction,
I'm going to fucking go in the other one.
Like if you,
if you back off then I'm not going to be as much of an asshole on stage,
but if you're going to be fucking sitting there and getting in my grill every
time I fucking say something,
it makes you,
it makes sure go hopefully even further in the other direction because comics
are telling me they're going on stage out here and see other comedians in front
of just a regular crowd.
It's not a benefit.
Like again,
if you're doing a cancer benefit,
they go,
hey,
just don't do any cancer jokes.
I get that,
but it's just a comedy show.
And they go and don't talk about this.
Don't talk about that.
They'll talk about get these fucking,
these
people are going to undo everything that Lenny Carlin and prior these guys went
to jail.
They went to jail.
So,
you know,
and because they did that,
believe it or not,
a lot of these female comics that are onstage now talking about their fucking
vaginas for 45 minutes,
you wouldn't be able to do that if it wasn't for them.
And now it's becoming this fucking thing where,
I don't know,
I don't,
I really just am baffled and every time I think like,
okay,
well we're going to come out of this ridiculously childish time and stand up
where,
where everybody is acting like comedians of all of a sudden presenting
legislation that is going to be turned into law rather than,
it's just up this somebody just,
just being an idiot.
MMM.
I Dunno,
I was doing this
some fucking club.
I'm not going to say the club was to the club and like,
uh,
I was making fun of white women how they act like they're oppressed.
You know what I mean?
When they're really just sitting in the Jacuzzi with me,
you know,
how they get sidestep their white privilege because they weren't allowed to vote
90 years ago,
you know?
So,
um,
oh,
just got the right to vote 90 years ago or whatever the fuck a hundred years
ago.
Um,
you know,
obviously just being a dick and this white woman in the crowd just goes,
I just got,
yeah,
just like that.
Right.
And uh,
I'm like that.
That's all you got is he's like what?
I had to say it like she's literally patting yourself on the back for how brave
she was.
The one is fucking hilarious.
Who's just like the complete lack of passion and fire.
The way she protested what I said just,
it just really shows like how unaffected you are.
Bye Bye.
Bye.
Whatever the fuck it is you're complaining about.
You know what I mean?
Truly oppressed people when they heckle.
When you say you crossed the line,
when they fucking heckle you,
you feel like,
oh fuck,
I went too far.
It isn't,
you don't sound like I was saying she sound like she was down the bottom of a
well.
So anyways,
I dunno,
I was not bringing these Steven Brody Stevens positive vibes to that show.
I was a,
I was being a bit of a Dick.
So whatever I'll,
I'll take,
I always take my 50% of it,
you know.
Um,
so anyways,
I go on to London today.
Let's look up where old freckles is going to be.
I don't even know.
I think I started Liverpool,
which I'm very excited about.
She loves you.
Yay Liverpool.
Right?
That's where a the four fucking
uh,
Marchetti cancer from the Beatles.
Let's see here.
Let's go to my website.
[inaudible] dot com everybody,
if you're following along in your program,
Bill bird.com I'm going to be,
yes,
I'll be in Liverpool.
Oh,
would you look at that?
Not until the 26th.
So I actually get an extra day here.
I fly today.
Today's the 24th.
By the time I land will be the 25th.
That gives me a chance to fucking chill out.
I'm there for two days.
Rumor has it most salads coming to the show.
Kidding.
I really fell out following the fucking soccer.
I tried.
I fucking tried.
Um,
Jim Breuer has the funniest fucking bit about Americans trying to get into
soccer.
Go once every four years.
You try to get into it,
you buy the Jersey and he just starts imitating them flopping all over the
place.
But I will say this,
I do really,
really enjoy this sport now and I do see the beauty in the skill and all of that
shit now.
Like,
you know,
I'm not 100% the stupid Yank,
making fun of the world's most popular sport and uh,
it is an all faking because I saw a moat sallow a couple of times on a
breakaway.
That's what they call it,
the hockey,
I don't know what the fuck they call it in,
uh,
in your football over there.
But like he's,
you know,
in the clear in this guy just runs up behind him.
He just sticks his leg out and dragged his clique down the back of his fucking
calf.
But what was funny,
cause he was on the breakaway,
most shook it off and then kick the [inaudible] kicked it in the net.
But if he was anywhere else,
he would've collapsed on the field,
like he got shot.
Although,
you know,
having said all that,
I would not want somebody to do that to me.
So it's,
it's not all,
uh,
it's not all faking.
So I'm in Liverpool and the 26th and the 27th,
28th them in Glasgow,
uh,
and then the 29th,
I'm off.
And then the f the first and second I'm in Birmingham and then Manchester,
legendary Manchester.
Uh,
and then where it,
Yo,
and then I have two days off.
What the fuck?
Then I get two days off and then I,
I,
I'm at Royal Albert Hall on the fourth and fifth taping my neck stand up
special.
And um,
you know what I was,
uh,
watching all these clips on Steven Brody Stevens and I came across,
I went to his Instagram and all of that stuff and uh,
I was watching,
I don't know,
somehow I ended up coming across this quote that Zach Galifianakis had that I'm
really going to take to heart because I've been just working my fucking ass off.
And it was basically saying,
you know,
don't feel like you have to be,
working all the fucking time.
I don't,
I can't paraphrase,
he said it perfectly of course,
but I kind of took it to heart like,
you know what if I just fucking chilled out for a couple of weeks?
Um,
I got that German Irish thing where you just go until one day you fucking like,
oh,
what's that pain in my chest?
And then you just fall forward into your fucking mushy peas and then that's it.
MMM.
So I'm going to try to,
uh,
I'm going to try to be around for a few mean I don't know how long I could do it
because there is a part of me that goes fucking nuts after four days of not
doing stand up.
But,
uh,
I think I'm going to go a little bit easy here over the next couple of months
and rather than just run out,
because what I usually do is I immediately,
I'll take like two days off after I do a special and I really immediately get
right back to the club.
And I,
and I,
I tried to get it going again.
And,
um,
I think this time when I'm going to do is actually take a little bit of time off
from doing stand up and,
and rather than just trying to force a new hour,
I'll go live a life that sort of writes the next hour.
Hopefully.
Hopefully that'll happen.
They'll watch you guys later on this year.
You know,
right off my special comes out.
I just saw him.
It's like half to save jokes.
It's fucking freckled conch sucks.
Um,
all right,
so there's 23 minutes.
I don't have the advertising reads yet,
so I'm going to finish this one tomorrow when I'm overseas.
Uh,
once again,
I'm absolutely,
um,
heartbroken.
That's such a special person.
Like Stephen is no longer with us,
but I am like
so inspired by the life that he lived and so happy to have known him only a
little bit is this little as I knew him and uh,
that I actually got to see him and I don't know,
man.
It's,
I don't know.
It's the weirdest feeling I've ever had after somebody had known that's died
where it's just like he just,
that there's even a,
a like a happiness.
I have just,
I,
I mean know what otherwise I think,
cause I just looked at his life and saw the effect that he had on people,
you know,
and he just kind of think like,
yeah man,
he got it.
He got it.
You know,
he
was a,
yeah,
just a,
an unbelievably positive positive force.
And the lesson I learned when Patrice died is that,
you know,
you don't own these people,
they're just gifts that you get and you don't get to decide when they go.
And that's sort of the,
a cruel thing that you continue to learn.
Yeah.
But,
um,
I dunno,
looking at his body of work,
you know,
I know personally I'm going to try to be a little bit less of a content,
try to live up to the high standard that he set.
All right.
Okay.
And with that,
I'll read some advertising here from London and with the magic of editing,
this will only be a half a second delay.
Okay.
And through the magic of editing.
I am now in Liverpool,
England.
Okay.
That only took half a second through the wonderful world of editing.
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
Oh God.
MMM.
So I'm in Liverpool now.
The driver was going,
you know,
you can go see where the Beatles fucking did all their first shows,
which I really think that's gotta be like the cheers of Liverpool.
Just going to walk in there.
Yep.
Right over there.
Right over there with where they're not right now.
That's where they were.
MMM.
I Dunno,
I'm just,
I don't have a show tonight,
so I'm just sitting here trying to figure out the goddamn heating system here,
which I can't figure out.
I don't know how to turn it on.
It pressed every fucking button.
And you know,
I brought a fucking adapter and whenever I bring a mixer,
I always blow out my fucking mixer.
And Lo and behold,
I plugged it in before I plugged it into the mixer.
And I just heard that the plug just goes like [inaudible] was just like,
well,
I just fried that fucking thing.
Even with the fucking adapter.
I Dunno how it happens.
MMM.
It didn't fry my computer,
but my computer has three prongs.
The mixer only has two.
Is that what problem is?
Somewhere in there?
Was it not grounded?
Was there too much of a surge?
Any electricians that can help me out?
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
but anyways,
let's continue.
Let me read a little a advertising here.
Um,
stamps.com no one really has time to go to the post office.
it sounds like a fat person making excuses why they can't go to the gym.
You're busy.
Who's got time for all that traffic,
parking,
lugging all your mail and packages?
It's a real hassle,
man.
That's why you need stamps.com.
One of the most popular timesaving tools for small businesses assistance is
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the post office.
stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the post office right to your
computer.
Whether you're a small office sending invoices,
Jesus Christ,
um,
on an online seller,
shipping out products,
or even a warehouse,
sending thousands of packages a day.
stamps.com can handle it all with these.
Simply use your computer.
Why is that fucking thing doing that?
MMM,
totally.
Uh
Oh,
what am I simply use your computer.
It's simple with stamps.com you get five.
Where the fuck is simple?
Use Your computer to print us officially was postage 24,
seven for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail,
any way you want to set once your mail is ready,
just handed to your mail carrier or drop it in a mailbox.
It's that simple.
A stamps.com you get 5 cents off every first class stamp and up to 40% off
priority mail.
Right now,
my slash our listeners get us,
oh,
I guess I'm supposed to say my cousin.
I'm by myself.
My listeners get a special offer that includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any longterm commitment.
Just go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter bar.
All right,
that's it.
Um,
all right,
let's talk about some shit here.
Uh Huh.
All right.
So I did some more sets in in New York head,
great sets Thursday night and then Friday and Saturday I had like those sort of
typical New York sets where,
you know,
I dunno,
it's just the,
I dunno what I don't,
I don't get it.
I was updating making fun of women and then this woman in the crowd,
white woman of course just goes back.
You right.
So I just started making fun of her and she just goes,
what?
I had to do it,
you know,
like what she did was unbelievable and brave and all of that type of shit.
And it's just like,
you know,
I dunno if you just heard it.
It's just like these fucking white women who are acting like they're repressed.
It's like you're white.
Okay.
That's my joke.
It's like you're in the,
in the Jacuzzi with me.
Stop this.
Stop it this fucking whining all the fucking time.
Like,
like you really this oppressed minority,
you know,
is this,
you could tell how oppressed she was by the level of passion she had when she
was yelling.
She's like,
hey fuck you had to say like no passion,
no fire,
no pain,
whatever.
Oh,
I not only know and all it's doing is just caused me to say more ignorant shit
that I wouldn't be saying if they weren't fucking act in that way.
So,
um,
just had,
it's just a really weird,
I don't know,
somebody actually wrote me a letter talking about the Caroline show,
which I mean I had a good time,
but by no means was it a smooth show,
said,
hey,
oh Billy,
thanks for coming out and putting on a great show at Caroline's.
You were absolutely hilarious.
I listen to your podcast and after agree with you,
the crowd wasn't typical New York.
I'm born and raised New Yorker and noticed a ton of what I'm sure were hipster
transplant.
I don't,
I think they're just younger people now
and I just think it's a product of being on social media.
And seeing everybody getting in trouble.
Maybe that's what it is because one of the Times I was doing a show in this guy
was like laughing but he wouldn't look at me and he was almost like looking down
and then looking across at his friend like,
like he wanted to laugh but he was afraid too.
I don't know.
It's strange.
Then he goes,
a couple of people even kept looking over at me for laughing so much.
Just want you to know that US natives and longtime New Yorker is really
appreciated and thoroughly enjoyed your show.
I hope you weren't too put off because I look forward to seeing you perform here
again soon.
Oh yeah.
I mean I'm not going to fucking quit coming to New York.
I just,
I'm having a difficult time trying to figure out what exactly it is that I'm
doing.
I feel like a three year comic when I go to New York.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
But it is what it is.
You know,
it's dictated by the young,
not the old.
So they are setting the tone and I guess I have to figure out how to adjust to
it.
Um,
oh,
and all Robert Kraft,
Robert Kraft getting all this shit for,
I don't know what,
you know,
the man simply was trying to buy a strip mall and he just went over there and he
was checking out some of the stores.
What is the problem?
I think it's such fucking bullshit.
That's just because he's famous.
I was talking to this copy because anytime we bust a rub and tug,
he goes,
you're trying to get the people that run it.
You don't get the Johns,
you just scare them and you let them go.
But all of a sudden he's a famous guy.
So now it's just like this big deal,
you know?
And everybody's just like,
why if you Robert Crap,
do you need to go to a rub and tug?
And I would say that's because that's how annoying it is to have a woman in your
life.
You can just get what you want without all the fucking bitch moaning and
complaining.
MMM.
Well,
I don't know why he went.
If he did to man,
it's all fucking alleged anyways.
You know,
it did happen to Florida.
So I mean,
we've been beaten up on the dolphins for so long.
I'm sure that's why they didn't fucking let them go.
But,
uh,
it's great that it happens because it gives people,
you know,
who hate Boston because they want all these fucking championships.
Um,
my favorite thing is when he talk about all the championships that they've won
and like,
people bring up like the eagles or the giants,
that it's just like,
dude,
they,
they went six and three.
I mean,
you're not gonna win all of them.
I will take those three losses all day long to win six Superbowls.
Um,
yeah.
All fucking day long.
All Day long.
I'll take the 86 year fucking curse of the bay.
Yeah.
To come back down three games to none
and,
and do what they've been doing.
I mean,
it's like,
it's,
yeah,
it's the pain that makes it great.
Um,
so anyways,
any way to say it properly,
let me read a few more of these podcasts might be a little bit short because I'm
beyond jetlagged and uh,
thank God I don't have a show tonight,
but now I'm like wide awake because I came here and,
uh,
I couldn't sleep on the plane.
I watched two movies that I really enjoyed.
I watched white boy Rick.
I got to give a shout out to that.
I mean,
Matthew mcconaughey is always great.
He's always great.
But the two people that played as kids,
um,
white boy Rick movie.
Let's see here.
Yeah,
I just thought the acting was superb in that movie.
Really,
really good movie.
And then I also saw a,
I'm not be able to figure it out.
There's IMDP.
Um,
I also saw,
uh,
the,
the Freddie Mercury movie
Bohemian rhapsody.
All right,
Richie Merit fucking killed it.
And then Bel Powley,
both of them were fucking amazing.
A really good movie.
Well,
these are also airplane reviews,
but I still think it was,
you know,
whenever you're in an airport,
Judah Friedlander used to always say that when you run a movie,
every fucking movie is good.
Um,
but these are actually really good movies.
And then I also saw a,
yeah,
that Bohemian rhapsody,
Bohemian rhapsody.
And you always,
the funniest part of that movie for me when I saw the original reviews of
Bohemian rhapsody,
it's how I feel about that song today.
I don't know,
but it's just overplayed.
But that SOG drives me up the wall.
I see a little silhouette of a man.
No,
no,
no.
My mom,
me and my mum,
it's just like,
oh my God,
I get it.
You could sing Jesus Christ about a fucking through line of a thought here.
Um,
but I,
I really liked,
uh,
I liked that movie,
but,
um,
and I was,
I was in the air and missed all the,
uh,
all the Oscar stuff.
But you know,
I thought it was hilarious that spike Lee was upset.
It's just funny to meet when adults get mad that they don't win a fucking
trophy.
You know,
it's just like,
what,
why do you give a shit?
Didn't you see how,
how they treated Martin Scorsese?
How long did he have to wait before he fucking,
before he did fucking,
uh,
if,
when he finally got best director,
when they finally gave it for them,
it wasn't,
it wasn't even his best one.
It should have been for the other ones.
It's like,
that's what's going to happen to you.
You know,
they fucked in Zelle on hurricane and then give him for the,
for that fucking King Kong.
Hey God,
not that on me.
They were always like a movie.
You're too late.
You know.
I don't,
I don't know why.
Why would you waste your time getting that fucking,
I dunno.
Upset.
I did like that he was dressed like prince,
his grandfather though.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
anyway,
uh,
I,
and most of those other movies I didn't see,
uh,
I,
I didn't see,
so I dunno.
What,
what,
what are you going to do?
All right,
the next thing I got here,
somebody of course,
giving me shit for a saint.
I felt bad for Jessie.
Smollett I just felt bad as far as like,
oh my God,
he's got to feel like the biggest fucking asshole lever in this guy.
Of course,
gets all passionate about it because why would you get passionate about the
corporations that dictate our foreign policy?
And I've literally bankrupted this country.
When you can get mad at an actor that got 100% busted for what he did and nobody
got hurt other than him,
you've totally destroyed his screen so they can feel safe,
bad.
You hope.
Who's could we rebounds?
The guy who was willing to let two innocent people rot in jail.
I don't think he thought they were going to get caught considering he was acting
like it was two white people.
I think what,
what was supposed to happen was they were supposed to sort of semi beat him up.
He was supposed to blame it on fucking raw,
uh,
white people and like the two guys who did,
is that what you're saying?
The Guy was trying to cause even more racial division and anger in this country.
Uh,
he didn't increase it or decrease it.
It wouldn't have,
it just would've just been another fucking story that lasted for three days.
It is where it is and will remain that way until people grow the fuck up.
Uh,
the guy who terrorized his coworkers by sending fake hate mail with mysterious
white power powder in it to his place.
Work Paul your head out of your ass.
Bird.
All right.
Maybe I was wrong about that.
I thought it'd be more of a unique take other than to say,
you just said what everybody else said.
Congratulations sir.
You,
no,
I still feel sorry for is you who does not have an original fucking,
I take what everybody else thinks.
Oh,
that's entertaining.
I mean,
if I just did that,
I could just be that big headed fucking lady who's that lady who does that show?
And she turns her head to the side like Jim Rome,
you know,
she gets all mad about cases about people who you've been just horrific things
have happened to them,
but if horrific things didn't happen to them,
then she wouldn't have a mansion.
So the whole show is kind of a weird thing to watch.
Um,
yeah.
Might as well be her.
She looks like the,
the,
the cousin of that woman who had the slave themed wedding,
who used to do the cooking show on the fucking food network,
whatever fucking name is.
Um,
she's,
you guys think I'm in a bad mood.
Watch that person show always with this scowl on their face.
She looks like that fucking monster in uh,
the fuck is it?
The bugs bunny.
You know,
monsters have such interesting lives or whatever used to say,
uh,
when bugs bunny was doing the things here,
that no arm fucking monster.
Right.
Um,
anyways,
sorry.
This is all jet lag.
Fucking horse shit.
Uh,
the fuck am I talking about here?
Yeah.
I,
anytime I see somebody just completely fucked their life up on some level human
being,
the human being,
I just,
I just feel bad.
I got God,
what did you do?
You know,
I don't condone it and think they should and I definitely think they should be
punished.
I don't know why I was looking at that.
Like we'll get that fucking Bernie Madoff guy.
I just can't imagine just sit.
I guess I'm looking at it like the person actually has empathy for other people.
Maybe they don't.
I'm putting myself into that situation where I would be going like,
Ah God,
okay.
Just every day everybody's smiling,
you're the greatest bill.
Thanks and making me all this money and I going to be like,
thank you.
Not to say that I haven't been a piece of shit in my life.
Well maybe that's what of this cause I've bet a piece of shit so I don't know.
Hey,
excuse me for fucking feeling bad for an actor who made it and then fuck the
whole thing up.
That is going to be the most bizarre way ever to try and get a raise.
But I still don't think that that's why he was doing it.
I think he had like some sort of victim fantasy or something like that.
I think it was more that I don't think that that's how you get a raise in and
I'll see if he really thinks that that's the way it was.
The was a way to get a raise.
Like there was the whole fucking thing was so crazy.
I feel like there's something about him that he's not all there and now he just
making fun of somebody that has some sort of mental issue,
I dunno.
Or
He's like the world's dumbest criminal.
Maybe that's what it is.
I don't know.
But you know what sir,
I will try to pull my head out of my ass and,
and,
and have your thoughts,
which is what everybody else thinks and that'll be an entertaining podcast.
Welcome to what everybody else thinks.
I'm your host Bill Burr,
uh,
the new green deal.
Sir,
did you get this mad that the first mammal went extinct due to human induced
global warming?
Did you have that level of passion for it?
All right.
The new green deal,
Yo Billy planet puts
I'm into saving the environment and I've been abstaining from plastic bags and
straws and buying the new iPhone every year for most of my life.
But I'm starting to question the narrative of certain things.
Okay.
Uh,
you talked about AOC,
I dunno what that is.
The young Congress woman with big ambitions wasn't sure if you heard this,
but in the New York green deal,
she's posting,
there was a line item supporting those who are not able to work in those who are
not willing.
Uh,
granted,
this isn't likely to happen.
I think it's insane to suggest that someone should get a check for sitting
around on their ass.
My question is,
if the US government decided to do this in civil war was pending,
would you leave the country or refuse to pay taxes?
Jesus Christ,
dude,
that,
that you went fucking vertical on that last line.
I mean,
if the US government decided to do it,
what the fuck?
What could I do about it?
I mean,
I,
I guess I would,
I essentially work for free.
MMM.
I Dunno,
but it's,
what's killing me is,
is we,
we have the money to not with all the money that we pay in taxes.
If we would get out of these fucking wars,
which are going nowhere,
and I've just bankrupted us and made a very few amount of people in this
country,
super fucking rich.
Okay.
You wouldn't have to then in like this person is now coming along and going
after people and she's not,
she's not going to be able to get all of those super rich people do not have
their money in this country.
I saw this fascinating thing,
I talked about this before,
how they,
they,
they get it out of the country,
you know their corporation is set up a in cooperation and one of these fucking
islands and all the money goes there.
And then there were an employee of that corporation and then they set up another
corporation in a different Ireland,
different company.
And then that debt cooperation bills,
the first one and then there's another one in another country and that one
builds this one and they just keep moving all of the money throughout these
islands.
All these key is is it's different countries.
So with each country,
the IRS,
I guess the amount of red tape they have to go through and at each stop the
corporation air quote corporation pays off somebody locally.
So it does cost them money to do that,
but not nearly as much as what they would pay in the United States.
And then when I get to like the seventh or eighth fucking place,
that corporation
then gives the person in the United States who doesn't want to pay taxes,
gives them a alone yeah.
Gives them the money back in the form of alone,
which isn't taxable.
And then they just never pay it back.
And the in the corporation quote forgives the loan.
So the taxes that that person paid was paying off people in each one of those
countries before it came back.
MMM.
Which is very sophisticated and I don't know,
that's how they fucking do it now.
This woman is not going to get those people.
What she's going to do is get,
like I said,
stand up comedians that are suddenly selling tickets.
She's got to get kids out of college that,
you know,
created movement watches or s or started an APP.
She's going to basically be going after and taxing the shit out of what makes
this country great.
The fact that you can come from nothing and you can get to that,
the absolute heights,
you know,
depending on how hard you work,
your idea and your luck,
anyone can make it.
Um,
she's going to be going after that and completely ignoring
these corporations that have bankrupted this fucking country.
Polluted the fucking drinking water.
Turned up our,
our,
our food supply into poison had made money,
millions and billions of dollars in pharmaceutical,
uh,
the pharmaceutical industry and,
and,
and with all these people overdosing and Ali's families that are ripped apart,
then Jenny,
she's not gonna go after any of those fucking people.
She's just going to get someone like me who's just a fucking individual.
That's it.
You saw what happened when Trump tried to tip,
pull the troops out of Syria.
You saw how both fucking Democrats and Republicans are like,
whoa.
They would,
that's where their bread is buttered by keeping those corporations making all
that money on that fucking war,
on those fucking wars.
And then when they're done,
they then get to go around and give speeches and that's how they wash their
fucking bribe money.
And you watched this woman for all these big ideas she has.
She's going to come out the other side.
She's going to be a multi,
multi,
multi fucking millionaire.
She's going to have a fucking book deal.
She's going to be on TV.
She's going to go on the talk show circuit and everybody's going to just sit
there and talk about what a fucking inspiration she is.
And um,
you know,
it,
it's,
it's just,
it's all bullshit.
And then meanwhile,
you know,
anybody who fucking,
when I had the balls to go after a dream and sleep on a futon until they were
like 38 and started making some money is going to be paying 70% taxes.
I guess that that's,
that's the solution to it.
I don't know.
I,
it doesn't seem like,
you know,
I know a lot of fucking people that if you just gave them a check every month
would just sit on their fucking ass and play video games.
Um,
just because this changing technology,
you have to fucking join it.
Learn how to fucking fix a robot's ACL or some shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
I'm sure there's a bunch of mechanics out there right now.
If you're smart,
you start to learn how to fix a an electric vehicle rather than sticking with
gas combustion engines.
Kind of trying to keep yourself ahead of the fucking game.
That's what you have to do.
You've got to fucking adjust.
Right?
I don't think the solution is to turn around,
you know,
I,
if I was running shit to take more than 50% income tax off of anybody,
regardless of where that,
how much money they're making should be fucking criminal.
There's no way the person who did the job should make less money then the person
taxing you.
Um,
I dunno,
that's just my,
my fucking opinion.
What the hell do I know?
I imagined some will tell me I needed to take my head out of my ass,
but I would imagine if we,
you know,
converted to fucking solar power and electric cars and all of that,
we would take a massive,
massive bite out of the Middle East and all of those people that fund these
fucking terrorist groups and two things,
they wouldn't have the money.
So to be any sort of a threat to us,
we wouldn't be fucking over there.
And eventually they would just go back to fight in each other the same way they
fucking did in eastern Europe.
When Russia pulled out,
they went right back to picking up their fights.
They were like,
where,
where are we?
And they went right back to fucking killing each other.
So I dunno,
I know I'm oversimplifying all of this shit,
but um,
I would think because we're their biggest customer that if we pulled out of
there,
that would massively hurt any sort of terrorist groups ability to try and go
after us.
You know,
I don't know the fuck the one out.
Why do you guys ask me such deep questions?
You know,
I don't fucking read the paper.
Write a long time.
Ozzy lady listener,
a good day bell long time listener here from Melbourne,
Australia.
Who would love to hear your take on my situation?
All right,
well,
did you realize you have to listen to my bed,
Aussie,
Aussie accent there?
I'm in the second half of my twenties out here.
We call that your late twenties.
I work in a TV job.
I love,
I'm independent,
have great friends and enough hobbies slash personal interests to keep me busy
and entertained in everyday life.
I've been told I'm a catch,
but it ain't all rainbows and sunshine.
Uh,
not only am I single,
but by my cynicism,
by my citizen has become so powerful that it's compromising my ability to date
or trust,
I think you want to say.
But my cynicism,
a bit of a background here years ago,
I was in a longterm relationship with ended in heartache for me.
And since then I've been through a sequence of disappointing dating experiences,
which has left me more lonely and unlovable each time people have named me good
luck,
chuck,
because whenever I get involved with anybody,
they settled down with the next person.
They come across.
I fear and becoming an angry person.
Men seem to think I'm more of a good time than along than a long time or a good
answer for boredom.
Uh,
I also need seem to attract men in relationships or worse,
married.
MMM.
But how can I become less of a cynic?
The reality is that some people just don't end up finding someone.
Well,
not with that attitude.
Uh,
they go through life falling in love alone or not at all.
My mother has,
has been single for 10 years and doesn't intend on changing that.
Uh,
do you think some people are meant to be alone?
Was there ever a point in your life where you thought you'd end up alone chairs
and go fuck yourself?
Absolutely.
I did.
And I went through the same shit that you're going through.
Yeah.
And I had,
you know,
women I dated and then I fucked it up and then they would go on the next guy.
They'd marry him.
Yeah.
I had that happen a couple of times.
MMM.
And then I dated,
you know,
thought went for awhile.
I thought women were psychos and then I just realized that what I was doing was
I kept going after roughly the same kind of person.
I kept fishing in the same poisoned pond,
if you will.
I think you just need to get a little therapy and become a little more positive.
And obviously if somebody is married or in a relationship,
you shouldn't,
you know,
I think that should be one of your first fucking questions.
MMM.
And there has to be something that you're doing.
And I'm saying this as,
as,
uh,
as a way as a positive thing that if that's what you're attracting,
there has to be something that you're doing that,
that can only happen so many times before.
You got to be figuring out what the fuck am I doing?
That's what I did was psycho women when I was just like,
you know,
[inaudible] chicks is psychos.
And after a while,
once you date,
like the third,
fourth,
fifth one in a row,
you're like,
all right,
what am I doing?
Oh,
I'm deliberately going after these people cause I'm afraid to commit.
And then when they break up with me,
there's no fucking heartache because they're out of their fucking mind.
Um,
so
I think some people were meant to be alone,
but it doesn't sound like you are.
If you are meant to be alone,
you would be way more okay with it than you are.
And this doesn't just seem like you're looking at the herd and it's making you
question yourself.
You sound like you want to find love.
So what I would do is take some of your TV money and I would get a good
therapist and I would do some work on yourself and
uh,
start fishing in a different pond.
How about that?
Did I oversimplify what was going on?
I probably did.
MMM.
Ways.
Any way.
I'm just gonna keep saying anyways,
I think it's one of one of my charms that I don't,
I don't have command with my own language.
Um,
all right.
That is the,
uh,
that is the podcast.
Geez,
we got fucking deep on this one.
Huh?
Passing is Steven Brody Stevens,
my how to solve the fucking Middle East problem.
The audacity to be doing that.
And uh,
I don't know what else.
Look at it as Keith Robinson just texted me,
he's like,
ha ha.
Looks like Robert Kraft won't be going to the White House this year.
Oh yeah,
I guess so.
Go cry with his six fucking trophies.
Okay.
Not to mention,
I,
you know,
I don't have,
is,
I don't know.
I've never had this experience before that my teams,
the team that wins everything.
It was,
it always this fucking petty.
That's all they do is just come up with petty shit.
Huh?
I guess he won't be plugging
[inaudible] that's like,
okay.
Yeah.
I guess we'll just have to fucking cry on Mark Trophies and move on.
It'd be they're not taking the team away.
Who gives a shit and not only that,
it's fucking,
it's Donald Trump.
Yeah,
he was probably,
he was probably the driver and the getaway car from the rub and tug.
Did you grab them by the policies?
Um,
anyways.
All right.
Anyway,
that is the,
uh,
that is the podcast.
Um,
congratulations to everybody out there.
That one,
the shiny things,
Mike condolences for those who didn't.
Um,
I hope people who watch movies and were offended by them can somehow move past
it and,
uh,
find a reason to get up in the morning tomorrow.
MMM.
People sort of,
it's a fucking award show.
I mean there
don't,
don't they fuck it up in your business to top salesman.
And everybody's sitting is fucking Goddamn Brown.
Noser he's banging the fucking,
his daughter was getting married to her.
That's why he fucking money.
You know,
isn't there always that shit?
There's always going to be that shit.
You know.
[inaudible] fucking crying.
So what's,
what a fucking great country.
This is,
you know,
it's such a great country.
People complain about the movies.
I didn't like the way it made people with red shirts.
Look.
Ooh.
Okay.
Well at least fucking polar bears too.
Fucking drowning.
Um,
add another flat screen to your fucking TVC.
You fucking TV room so you can fucking watch the Oscars and cry about it.
Um,
all right,
I'm off my fucking soapbox.
Uh,
here we go.
I'm in the bubble.
Everybody.
I am in the bubble this time next week.
What is going to be Monday?
And we'd be doing my first taping and then the next day I'll do my next taping
and then now we will be putting this hour and 30 minutes to fucking bed.
Uh,
I can't wait.
I'm very excited.
I miss my daughter and wife terribly.
And uh,
I'm really gonna take it easy this year.
I really am.
I'm talking to my agent.
I'm going to be the California kid.
I'm doing gigs out in fucking Cali and it's going gonna stay in the southwest.
I'm going to fluff.
I can't fly southwest of the Gig in under 50 minutes.
I'm not fucking doing it and I'm just going to fucking chill.
I got an acting Gig this summer.
Then I'm bringing my wife and kid along too,
and uh,
I'm just going to slip some life and let this thing come together.
Uh,
oh my God,
my wife sent me this video of my kids singing the abcs and I do this thing.
I don't know if I,
I probably already told you this shit.
So fucking jet lag.
But I do this thing the way I sing,
the abcs.
I go a,
B,
c,
d e f g,
H,
I,
J,
k l m n o,
p Gate,
you know,
bouncing up and down.
She just laughs and all that stuff.
So now she can do the abcs and she throws the haze in there.
She's like
[inaudible],
Hey t u v,
hey,
it's the cutest fucking thing over and it's all that matters in life.
And then you fucking put on the TV and you watch adults fucking whining because
they didn't get this star on their forehead.
Who gives a fuck?
You're making movies,
you're a millionaire,
you're bang and beautiful women.
You know,
what the fuck else do you need?
I wanted the shady thing.
I'd like the
Faculty Academy
fucking have to people in the world try and just get it fucking sandwich.
Boohoo I didn't get a trophy.
I will never get,
I will never fucking understand that.
But then again,
I do watch sports and I get excited that my team wins trophies and I'm about
ready to fucking trash.
Keith Robinson and his,
sorry ass fucking cowboys.
Who the Patriots just passed for more super bowl titles.
Um,
we one more super bowl titles.
What am I going to say to him?
We one more super bowl titles and the last two decades than the cowboys have one
in their entire fucking history.
Tom Brady has more rings than all the Dallas Cowboy quarterbacks combined.
Oh,
I,
I'll do,
I have some ammo and I have to take advantage of it now.
Cause I know when Tom Leaves and bill Belicheck with tires,
you know,
I have faith in like the fucking,
but also wait,
Robert Craft,
right?
Simply trying to buy a strip mall and checking out the stores.
That fucking guy,
arguably the greatest owner of all time.
When you look at his coaching hires,
he's hired three coaches.
Bill Parcells a fucking,
uh,
what's his name there?
Woo.
Just totally foolish.
Forgot his fucking name.
Pete Carroll.
Bill Belichick,
three for fucking three hall of famers.
That's two Superbowl,
three Superbowl,
nine Superbowls amongst all of them.
Amazing.
All right,
that's it.
That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I will talk to you.
Uh,
I'll check in on you in a couple of days.
I don't know where I'm going to be,
but I got Liverpool the next couple of,
uh,
the next couple of nights and uh,
very excited to be here.
I've never been here and as much as I was making fun of all that Beetle Shit,
I'm definitely going to go look at it.
You know,
I got it.
I go,
I'm not going to go to the pub where they fucking started,
and of course I'm going to go right,
and I'm going to,
you know,
I'm like,
I don't think I'm going to go to all their fucking houses,
Roy.
This is where Ringo was sleeping.
Was it?
How the fuck do I know that?
All right,
I'll see you.